hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play and okay
before I recorded that door kind of went
thumpy thump again so oh I'm not so sure
about that all right anyway I've got
some sawdust a perforated wooden box
still not used to the controls but I
don't have a clear idea you don't have a
clear face so sure bookcase just popped
up right out of the nemi
if I lubricate it with some sawdust I'm
not thinking clearly okay oh yes
someone said put the sawdust in the
puddle not sure what that's all about
but nope whoever said that it's a dirty
dirty liar let's see
so the canteens already filled I don't
need to do that so I've got some leaves
here some leaves the house is still
pretty dang empty yeah that's really
like ridiculously dark if you're like I
can't see anything that's pretty good
pretty damn dark okay so you got this
old saw here
maybe there's something I can used to
get the saw out can't use these two
together well screw you then something
down low
I love sawdust ooh what's this thing ah
what do we got here
Oh chunks of wood is there anything
under here ah anything come on
aha there we go what is that
clothes you remember the resembles a
blade of a knife like it what bloody
hell ah what's this n I click others oh
there's a lock here let's see okay
someone said something not sure what the
deal was with that they try to use this
on this yeah okay so I already have a
knife but okay
stuck bone hilt no okay
um apparently I think I need to get this
out in order to reattach it to the blade
see close is a strange drawing of eyes
on the board yeah who made it use need a
key for it wait didn't I get a key oh
the key was to the other thing damn it
if I can use this on that shut up how
could you think that maybe I put the Box
in the water perforated maybe I did
float no no like seriously got it like
try every single thing here no way no
way Jose no way to you so there's this
hole in the wall hole in the box
ha ha ha I was reaching there with which
I am well acquainted caster or and
pollux or the twins I'm uncertain of
which side of the sawmill faces them ok
can I take it back I can't take it it's
nailed how do you get nailed by the wall
I mean really
ok so what did that do certain if which
scientists all know faces them it's like
a spray of water there's ray of light
down there but either way I can't get to
it
so it's blocked up ok I don't know what
that did I don't know if we did anything
damn it - show me a picture I'm unsure
of which side the sawmill faces them
I'm not sure Oh Oh No
help my brother was in asleep just now
he's probably awake okay broken noses
before I need something to fix it okay
okay
heap of dried leaves okay he said was
broken need to fix it but it was on fire
before oh oh oh no oh no it makes no
sense oh no oh no oh no I thought this
game wasn't gonna be that scary
oh no oh okay I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
I'm tough what is this oh man
I don't know I don't even know what the
hell that was
Oh with this note say again obsessed by
such purity he stretched out his arm and
cut himself with the heated blade at
last he had fulfilled the right only
when he had seen his own blood pollute
the limpid water he realized he was
drawn to the truth ah cut myself blade
put in the puddle maybe and maybe maybe
maybe maybe he did blade maybe that's a
clue of what I'm supposed to do so
whoa where the [ __ ] did I go from
[Music]
shut up it jet good die it's like it's
expecting me to just wander around here
and put stuff in the way oh god just
shut up
you don't make I'm like trying every
combination of things I could possibly
do but wait he did knife blade he did
knife blade oh use it on myself in the
pot y'all oh oh oh oh oh you oh come on
use okay hey on examine image of a snake
entwined around the branch appears on
the blade well how does that help me a
snake around a snake around a branch wow
oh that was this song I thought it was
like like a meat okay cool knife blade
so if you do that a snake pops up but
how does that help me maybe when that
happens I gotta use the knife at a
certain time maybe now I can use the
knife on that I know
aha it makes no sense
you make no sense
there has to be some way to get maybe if
I heat it up again and use it on the
door here there's no obvious way to use
it on yourself so I'm not exactly sure
oh man
this is this is something else what was
that
Hey hi hi hi hi hi hi hi all right all
right okay okay there's got to be
something to do with this machine
because this is just here but it's got
no interactive things
and it's not sure what the hell was that
creping Ford's alright anyway I'm just
gonna jump cut it here I'm not gonna end
it here I'm just joking cutting it so
I'll see you in a second I'll be right
back right back jump cut okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Scottie something to do with this I've
been wandering around ah why whoa feeble
luminescence well what is that
I nearly luminescence radiating from the
panel I'd like to reach its end but I
can't see anything to walk on is this
what the guy meant when he said put this
on oh uh uh oh no no visible oh yeah
was that how odd in the center of the
putrid pond there is a gap in the sludge
the water looks so there looks pure so
pure I could drink it you drink it drink
it Katy drink it drink it how can I
think that you wanted to drink it evil
luminescence it was there all the time
yeah no kidding but what good does this
do me oh good this is dunya all right
blah blah I could drink it ah all right
maybe if I get Han ah yeah okay I'll
just get some Oh God good some yeah add
more to it maybe come on baby come on
don't weigh means no whammies oh yeah
then this does me no good
hey on we try try the thing I was doing
with the heated blade maybe now I cut
myself off it makes no you I need to
figure out how to frickin complete this
frickin frackin thing why can't I have a
hand and just jerk it out why is that
handled so hard to get it's just anal
not even a blade in it I probably have
the blade in it God just get out yeah I
swear I swear if I can't dig it out with
a friggin knife I swear I
okay why did that work I tried that
before I swear I feel strange Oh
Oh No oh hey how long has that been
there did I just see something was that
totally just a shadow uh-oh
who knew Oh yo-ho-ho stars arrows Julio
okay okay all right
oh look at that I'm out of time
whoa would you look at that oh sorry
guys I gotta go
actually that is all the time I got for
now so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye